well that was rough Detroit
so Detroit is a movie is that about
Detroit not really the movie Detroit
takes place in Detroit during the
Detroit riots of 1957 isn't about the
right not really the racial tensions in
this time in Detroit read an all-time
high the guitar strings snapped
rights are happening police are out
there to handle the right and Bill's
right and a lot of black people were
wrongfully in prison by the police
assaulted by the police so this movie is
the true story of what happened at the
Algiers motel during the Detroit riots
these officers believe they hear some
gunfire they go over there they
ransacked the place they line up these
black eyes and two white girls on this
wall they're all like we don't have a
gun and the cop leading this charge is
as blatantly razors dude don't like you
don't have a gun huh well we'll beat you
torture you we're going to smash a
confession out of one yeah that's more
or less this movie the movies directed
by Kathryn Bigelow so we have some
talent behind the camera here first of
all the one main racist cop in this
movie is played by will Poulter yeah
he's that bratty eyebrows kid from that
Narnia movie it was really good he
totally brought it in this movie he's
scary that's what I'm trying to say John
Blake is also in the movie he plays a
security guard he's optimistic too a
naive quality because it's neither doing
their jobs right it's gone to the world
kind of just what they got to do right
I'll keep telling myself that and John
boyega in this movie was great like
right when he comes on screen one of his
first couple lines you like that Blake
equality right there that's that charm
you know I've always been a fan of boy I
got a fan of him in this movie too and
I've heard some people call this movie
like it's a horror movie I feel like
that's a 50/50 statement I feel like
half the people who say it say it in a
positive light
the other half stayed in a negative
light I personally agree that it is a
bit of a horror movie in a positive
light
what's more horrific than seeing what
mankind is capable of at a personal
level to his fellow man
what this movie is is a tension grenade
or Adrenaline's pumping your hearts
going you feel like you are in that room
on that wall someone else gets hurt
there's nothing you can do about it
nothing they can do about it in the
guitar string tighten that's what this
movie is good at it's also very good at
making you feel that helplessness if the
movie she's showing you what's going on
not making you feel as helpless as the
ones on screen it really it kind of
comes across in effect the movie was
really good at making you feel like yep
there's nothing any of us can do I
didn't feel the title is misleading
it's called Detroit I'm sure Detroit's
out there like great guys thank you
probably should have been called Algiers
or LG
Motel Algeria's 57 some calling it
Detroit if it was about the Detroit
riots sure but it's not really about the
riots the majority of this movie takes
place in the hallway and a couple of
rooms in this motel moving does leave me
with a couple of questions concerning
the main officer he does something near
the beginning of the movie and whose
superiors like no you don't do that
you're actually a [ __ ] for doing
that I feel like that could have played
later on in the movie when we're dealing
with credibility and it never really
does so did he really do that thing in
the beginning did his superior and never
bring it up and I'll say the beginning
of this movie has some weird animated
setup it wants to give you information
backstory history on what led to the
racial tensions in Detroit the way it
does it is with this animation I just
didn't feel it fit and one contains a
unique take in a movie like this to give
us that much backstory but I didn't feel
it was necessary to know that it's
gotten to this point it's all kind of
sloppy when I didn't know it was about
the Algiers motel I thought the movie as
a whole is about to Detroit right so I
was like all right well glad I got that
weird messy backstory to know how it got
to this point I guess there wouldn't
concentrate on the Algiers motel I'm
like okay so all we had to know was that
the riots were happening and this
situation happened within the riot I
didn't have to know why the racial
tension got to that point to lead to the
rights to lead to the Algiers motel he
could have started out with black
screens some white text to give you some
of the backstory and then the riots
happened and then you go into the
Algiers motel if anyone wants to look
into it further google is out there we
have the Internet it's just one of those
movies that's focused in purpose but
large in scope the acting among
everybody in the movie was great the
tension is the backbone of this movie
it's uncomfortable it's supposed to be
uncomfortable
it's well-constructed it's well done
that's what I love movies can do they
can ultimately give you a history lesson
yes in a story that's 50 years old it's
going to be some dramatization here and
there in the movie but they've
reconstructed it the best way they could
movie like this needs to be handled with
a sense of responsibility and care I
feel like Kathryn Bigelow did that I
don't know how many times I'm going to
watch the movie that's the thing about
the movie like this how much replay
value does it have so it's kind of an
ironic writing that I say Detroit is
worth watching and worth buying on
blu-ray
point is is really good all right guys
so Detroit have you seen it what did you
think about it whatever you have thought
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you've seen here and
you want to see more click right here to
see more
you
[Music]